hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer question from one of my
face book readers Christian who runs a
company and is working with salespeople
and is asking me about compensation
so he's finding that the people who he
pays your salary to are not meeting
their sales quotas and are not doing a
good job and it's wondering if he should
move to a commission type of model so
Christian to help answer your question
good salespeople usually do like to run
on Commission they're usually very
competitive people they like closing the
deals and they know that the more they
close the more money going to make so
you definitely want to have a commission
component built in there the caveat
there is it often takes people a little
bit of time to get used to selling your
product so you want to have a buffer in
there where they can take a draw still
make money at the beginning and you know
not be out looking for other ways to
make money because they can't sell your
product so it might take three months it
might take six months just depends on
how long your sales cycle is you want to
make sure you supporting them through
that period so that when they get to you
know that Commission model they're able
to to make the money so I'd have a
commission model show them how much they
can make but be patient with them and
let them know that there's a ramp-up
period that you're going to support them
through so that they're not out you know
on the street trying to find other ways
to make money you know until they can
ramp up their sales the next thing is
I'd also make sure that I'm training
them so you're giving them all the
resources that they need to be
successful it's not just hey go out and
sell you know you're giving them a model
on how to do it hopefully you've done it
yourself before you have some experience
you can help them with or you have a
really good salesman already on stock
who can help part of the training as
well so your help support them your
champion them your believing in them and
not just saying you know go out and do
it without giving them any experience
and I'd also try to give them leads as
much as possible so if people are
contacting you by phone or email on your
website or Facebook or or there
contacting you try to give your
salespeople some leads as well so it's
not only up to them to go out and bring
in new leads if they see especially the
beginning that they can close a couple
sales it gives them some motivation
inspiration or I continue I want to do
better when I'm going to close more more
sales you know sales people there's
often writing highs and writing lows you
want to get them to those highs as
quickly as you can and there's nothing
that makes a salesperson you know more
high than closing a sale so try to get
them some warm leads as well support
their development especially at the
beginning so they get used to selling
the product and know how to do it and
they're gonna support your longer-term
so I would say move to a commission
model but just with the caveat of giving
them that base at the beginning to
support them to the transition period
and then try to give them as much
training and support and leads as
possible to make sure they're going to
be successful and be happy and help you
bury business for the long term so will
that help Christian those watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below
I always appreciate those and I'd love
to hear what you have to think if you
want to leave a comment under the video
if you have an extra thought for
Christian or if you have a question of
your own feel free to leave a comment
under this video and we'll see you on
the next episode
you